cela fait maintenant dix ans depuis la montée des
huit à toutes fins utiles, l'
humanité est partie c'était un virus créé
par des scientifiques dans le laboratoire, vous ne pouvez pas
honnêtement blâmer les singes où diable
je vais blâmer barry tué
après la planète déjà
avec autant de pièces mobiles, la
production est énorme,
nous essayons définitivement de construire un monde
qui se rapporte aux singes et à la façon dont ils vivent
c'est un mot de terrain incroyablement ardu
qui revient sans cesse à l'esprit est primitif
il y a le sentiment que tout a
été construit avec beaucoup de réflexion  mais
en même temps, avec des moyens très primitifs,
nous voulions le filmer en 3D dans des
lieux réels afin que vous puissiez vous sentir comme si
vous étiez dans la nature avec les
singes entourés par cet
environnement massif tellement stimulant qu'il
est mythique et épique  dans tous les sens
tu